das heißt dass anders als im frühjahr
und schwierige monate bevorstehen weil
bei niedrigeren temperaturen dieses
virus auch anders und noch aggressiver
reagiert ich komme gerade aus dem chor
oder kabinett und wir haben uns dort im
kreis zuständigen minister auch wieder
die aktuelle lage klar gemacht die macht
und sorgen an diesem montag 12 1097 neue
gemeldete infektionsfälle beim
robert-koch-institut das ist in etwa
eine verdreifachung in 14 tagen eine
verfünffachung seit mitte oktober
das ist exponentielles wachstum das uns
mit zunehmender geschwindigkeit auf eine
akute notlage in unseren krankenhäusern
zu laufen lässt und wir sehen das ja
auch an der zahl der koma patienten auf
intensivstationen die sich sozusagen in
den letzten zehn tagen auch wieder
verdoppelt hat von 1030 belegten betten
am 22 oktober auf 2061 belegte betten am
ersten november wir wissen auch dass die
zahl der auf den intensivstationen
liegenden patienten noch einmal zeitlich
verzögert zu der aktuellen fall zahl ist
das heißt die heute gemeldeten fälle
haben sich vor etlichen tagen infiziert
und die heute gemeldeten fälle werden
erst in 14 tagen überhaupt in den
intensivbetten statistiken sichtbar
werden dass das das heißt das was wir
heute dann intensiv patienten sehen dass
es das was ich vor etwa zehn bis 14
tagen abgespielt hat und weil wir sehr
stark steigende zahlen in den letzten
zehn tagen hatten werden wir auch weiter
steigende belegung der intensiv
kapazitäten sehen und zuzusehen wie wir
näher und näher an die belastungsgrenze
des personals und der strukturen in der
intensiv medizin kommen das kann keine
regierung verantworten das will die
bundesregierung nicht verantworten
und ich persönlich
will es auch nicht das heißt also wir
dürfen nicht zulassen dass dieses diese
schnelle verbreitung des virus unsere
gesundheitsämter immer weiter
überfordert schon bei den derzeitigen
zahlen ist es nicht mehr möglich die
kontakte jedes einzelne nachvollziehen
und das heißt dass praktisch viele
menschen infiziert durch die gegend
laufen ohne gewarnt worden zu sein ins
ferne die die keine symptome zeigen und
das heißt dass die sich wiederum daran
sich wiederum andere anstecken und weil
diese entwicklung so gelaufen ist weil
viele gesundheitsämter die kontakt nach
verfolgung nicht mehr schaffen haben wir
jetzt eine situation bei der in 75
prozent der fälle also drei viertel der
fälle die infektion nicht mehr
zugeordnet werden können das heißt man
kann nicht mehr sagen wo diese infektion
stattgefunden habe und deshalb müssen
wir wieder in eine situation kommen in
der die gesundheitsämter verpackten
nachverfolgen können sonst nimmt das
exponentielle wachstum immer weiter zu
und bei einer inzidenz von 150 oder 200
in einer kommune ist das nicht möglich
wir haben heute deutschlandweit eine
gemietete inzidenz von 127,8 infektionen
pro 100.000 einwohner in sieben tagen
wir müssen wieder in eine region von 50
infektionen sieben tagen pro 100000
einwohner kommen bis dahin können die
gesundheitsämter das einigermaßen
nachvollziehen
und das ist nun das ziel wieder in diese
region zukommen der maßnahmen der
nächsten vier wochen
sie sind hart das weiß ich und trotzdem
ist nicht mehr der zeitpunkt in dem wir
diese oder jene kleine variante machen
können oder einfach nur auf die regeln
hinweisen
wir wären dann halbherzig und das virus
bestraft halbherzigkeit deswegen haben
wir diese umfassenden einschränkungen
gemacht und es geht immer um die frage
weil wir wissen dass da ein enger zu
anhang besteht zwischen der zahl der
kontakte und der zahl der infizierten
das heißt wir müssen kontakte reduzieren
wo immer das möglich ist
das heißt als erstes home office zu
hause arbeiten nur immer möglich aber
die maßnahmen greifen dann tief in das
private leben ein keine urlaubsreisen
keine nicht unbedingt notwendigen
verwandtenbesuche keine feste und feiern
das freizeitangebot und die
kulturstätten werden geschlossen und zu
hause sollen sich so wenig wie möglich
menschen treffen
der aufenthalt im öffentlichen raum ist
beschränkt auf zwei haus stände sollten
diese haushalte größer sein als je fünf
personen in einer familie dann ist das
nochmal beschränkt auf maximal zehn
personen aber das eigentlich wichtig ist
die 2 house stände die zwei haushalte
und das bedeutet natürlich vier wochen
lang verzicht auf vieles was das leben
schön macht und das wissen wir sowohl
die ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten als auch wie in der
bundesregierung
wir haben lange abgewogen ob es einen
besseren oder milderen weg gibt wir
haben ihn nicht gesehen und deswegen
haben wir diese regelung schweren
herzens beschlossen aber eben auch aus
überzeugung wir glauben dass sie
geeignet sind unser ziel zu erreichen
und sie sind erforderlich um die
kontakte zu reduzieren
die wissenschaftsorganisationen haben
genau dafür ausgesprochen wir haben also
auch hier beratung gesucht und eine
massive einschränkung der kontakte
bedeutet entsprechend weniger
gelegenheiten zur ansteckung und wenn
wir das einem monat mit aller konsequenz
durchhalten kann das in dieser zweiten
welle ein wellenbrecher sein
das war's dann sind natürlich auch
zustande gekommen weil wir uns überlegt
haben was ist das allerwichtigste zum
funktionieren in unserem land und das
sind nach unserer meinung eine
infrastruktur die im gesundheitsbereich
dasteht und den pflegebereich
krankenhäuser pflege
das ist den
schaffts kreislauf so weit wie möglich
am laufen zu halten und für uns waren
das als lehre aus der ersten welle der
pandemie das offenhalten von schulen und
kindertagesstätten wir haben immer
wieder gesagt sie müssen als letztes
wort notwendig geschlossen werden hat
als erstes auf gemacht werden das letzte
mal war es genau andersrum deshalb jetzt
die bewusste entscheidung dass wir diese
kitas und schulen offen lassen
denn aber all diese kontakte unabdingbar
sind dann müssen andere eingeschränkt
werden und ob diese große gemeinsame
kraftanstrengung etwas bringt im monat
november
das hängt nicht nur von den regeln ab
sondern vor allem auch davon ob diese
regeln befolgt werden weil viele sich im
privaten leben abspielt weil viele
menschen sehr persönliche entscheidungen
treffen werden den treffe ich ihn treffe
ich nicht und das im auge haben sind wir
auf das mitmachen und auf die akzeptanz
und das verständnis der menschen in
unserem land angewiesen damit das
funktionieren kann
das heißt also jeder und jeder hat es in
der hand diesem november zu unserem
gemeinsamen erfolg zu machen
zu einem wendepunkt wieder zurück zu
einer verfolgbarkeit der pandemie und
wenn es das in den nächsten vier wochen
gelingen würde die ausbreitung des virus
zu bremsen dann schaffen wir uns die
voraussetzungen dafür einen erträglichen
dezember zu haben natürlich weiter unter
krone regeln so wie wir sie jetzt ja
schon seit vielen monaten kennen aber
wieder mit mehr freiräumen
wir haben heute pro oder kabinett über
die wirtschaftshilfen gesprochen die die
angeordnet die die unternehmen betrifft
die jetzt schließen müssen
der finanz und der wirtschaftsminister
werden sehr schnell und unbürokratisch
handeln und bis zu zehn milliarden euro
zur verfügung stellen
niemand ob gastronomen oder fitnessclub
leiter wird es mit seinem aus
einnahmeausfall in diesen nächsten vier
wochen an
einige lassen ich weiß dass viele
restaurants geschäfte und betriebe ja
große anstrengungen unternommen haben
und das kann die bedingungen arbeiten zu
können und das sind vorkehrungen die
noch sehr wertvoll sein werden denn wer
nämlich wieder in einer etwas freie zeit
hinein gehen können aber im augenblick
wegen der 75 prozent nicht mehr zuordnen
barren infektionen und wegen der
absoluten notwendigkeit kontakte zu
reduzieren können diese hygienemaßnahmen
nicht ihre wirkung entfalten und wir
sind uns auch einig dass die hilfen die
kultur erreichen müssen
und menschen die jetzt in diesem moment
wieder nicht auftreten können oder ihre
künstlich zeigen können
die leiden natürlich darunter und
bringen für uns alle für die ganze
gesellschaft damals ein opfer genauso
wie die restaurants bars und clubs auch
die kulturszene hatte ja mit viel viel
liebe und engagement möglichkeiten und
formen gefunden wieder arbeiten zu
können und wir wissen alle dass die
kultur für unser zusammenleben in der
gesellschaft existenziell ist dass sie
wichtig ist und für eine freie
gesellschaft central ist und umso mehr
schmerzt es jeden und auch nicht ganz
besonders dass wir auch hier kontakte
reduzieren mussten für den monat
november
es geht also nicht um das für jene
konzept für diese oder jede einrichtung
sondern es geht darum dass wir für die
gesamtheit aller kontakte in unserer
gesellschaft eine reduktion hinbekommen
die wissenschaftler sagen uns eigentlich
von 75 prozent aller kontakte und das
ist sehr sehr viel von 4 kontakten die
wir normalen zeiten haben drei vermeiden
und einen möglich machen
und wenn wir allein daran denken dass
schulen und kitas auf bleiben mit weit
über 10 millionen kindern dann ist das
schon eine große aufgabe
ich will zum abschluss noch etwas sagen
zu der kona waren es die jetzt von 21 5
millionen menschen heruntergeladen wurde
si
wir haben inzwischen von den
niedergelassenen laboren 152 von 165
angeschlossen
es wurden über diese waren zwischen 257
millionen testergebnisse übermittelt und
830.000 nutzer haben ihre positiven
testergebnisse dann weiter vermittelt an
ihre kontaktperson und leider sind wir
allerdings bislang nur bei 60 prozent
der positiv getesteten die ihre kontakte
auch weitergeben da liegt noch eine
große aufgabe auf die wir immer wieder
hinweisen wollen dass wir hier noch mehr
menschen dazu ermutigen wollen wenn sie
positiv getestet sind auch die
kontaktperson anonymisiert natürlich zu
informieren wir haben im gegensatz zum
früher einige lichtblicke
wir haben mehr und besseres material
wir haben neben dem pcr-test jetzt auch
die schnelltests sie an die schnelltests
zur verfügung die den schutz von
wohlhabenden gruppen also für menschen
die besonders risikoanfällig sind für
diese krone virusinfektion wir haben
bessere medikamente noch keine
durchschlagenden aber medikamente und
wir haben auch aus sicht positive
aussicht auf impfstoffe die in den
nächsten monaten zugelassen werden
könnten
aber es bleibt dabei so lange das alles
nur im ansatz da ist wie der impfstoff
noch in der entwicklung sicht befindet
auch keine durchschlagende medikamente
da sind müssen wir die nächsten vier
monate mit dieser pandemie leben und
alles daran setzen so viel wie möglich
die verfolgbarkeit die
kontrollierbarkeit hinzubekommen
sonst werden wir eine überlastung
unseres gesundheitssystems sehen was wir
unbedingt vermeiden
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren